[Música]
hola bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
áfrica siete días su magazine
informativo 100% dedicado al continente
africano aquí damos una mirada en
profundidad a los principales temas de
la semana en la cola de la humanidad
elecciones presidenciales en costa de
marfil desde que se anunciaron los
primeros resultados el presidente
alassane ouattara contaba con una fuerte
ventaja la posición que no quiere un
tercer mandato de guacara no reconoce
los comicios que reclama una transición
civil hasta la celebración de nuevas
elecciones tenemos informe desde abiyán
e inician en nigeria las audiencias de
un panel judicial para investigar los
casos de violencia policial en las
manifestaciones que justamente
rechazaban la brutalidad de los agentes
multitudinarias marchas se vivieron en
todo el país contra el escuadrón
especial antirrobo que fue disuelto tras
la represión social
israel y sudán anunciaron la
normalización de sus relaciones la
decisión provocó una serie de reacciones
del pueblo sudanés que pasan de la
indignación a una aceptación pragmática
este 31 de octubre costa de marfil
celebró elecciones presidenciales los
primeros resultados apuntaron a la
victoria del presidente alassane
ouattara los comicios estuvieron
marcados por un boicot de la oposición
contra el gobierno y no reconocen estos
comicios no quieren un tercer mandato de
guacara y reclaman una transición hasta
la celebración de nuevas elecciones
durante la jornada también se
presentaron episodios de violencia en
abiyán nuestra corresponsal mariam con
él tiene los últimos detalles
después de tres meses de crisis
preelectoral los marfileños votaron en
una atmósfera especial con 22 con datos
hoy con hombre para escalas ingreso que
decidieron de boicotear las elecciones
criticaron el actual presidente alassane
ouattara por querer hacer un tercer
mandato inconstitucional según ellos
este período preelectoral se caracterizó
por la violencia entre los partidos y la
policía pero también entre las
diferentes comunidades del país que
provocó docenas de muertos y heridos el
día de las elecciones se desplegaron
35.000 fuerzas de seguridad en todo el
país pero no todos los marfileños
consiguieron a votar porque los
partidarios en pedirán que hicieran en
varias localidades según la asociación
en vigo el 23 por ciento de los de los
marfileños disculpa no pudieran votar
cientos de observadores nacionales e
internacionales están cuestionada la
credibilidad de estas elecciones
algunos como cortes center hablan de una
inclusive boicoteada que deja un país
fracturado
las elecciones de este año en costa de
márfil han estado marcadas por episodios
de violencia en el país hay profundas
diferencias entre los ciudadanos sin
embargo todos defienden la paz y la
reconciliación después de que el país
entrara en una guerra civil tras los
comicios de 2010 dejando más de 3000
muertos
yo pudo es un crisol de culturas de más
de un millón de personas es un bastión
del partido
lohan bajó y fue escenario de masacres
durante la crisis poselectoral de 2010
2011 en agosto de este año la atención
volvió a estallar después de que el
presidente alassane ouattara anunciara
que se presentaría a un tercer mandato
las protestas aquí han sido rápidamente
reprimidas por la policía en un intento
por evitar una repetición de la
violencia de 2011 los esfuerzos de
diálogo en este vecindario se han
intensificado al de minis en 2010 y 2011
después de la crisis todos hicieron un
esfuerzo por aceptar a unos ya otros
pero hoy los mismos políticos de antes
están creando una situación que las
víctimas del pasado están comenzando a
tener nuevamente en situación julio 21
más agua para el grupo apoya la idea
pero muchos están desilusionados y
amargados por las promesas incumplidas
se suponía que el proceso de
reconciliación tenía dos pilares
principales el primero era la
indemnización de las víctimas y es que
la aduana paga hasta ahora no hemos
recibido compensación por eso la
reconciliación va mal y es que la a la
reconciliación gamal el segundo pilar de
la reconciliación era la justicia la
amnistía para los perpetradores
introducidos por votar en 2018 provocó
reacciones encontradas es difícil juzgar
exactamente qué también avanza la
reconciliación en un país diverso sin
embargo y sin duda los fantasmas del
pasado siguen presentes
comenzaron las audiencias en un panel
judicial del gobierno del estado de
lagos en nigeria después del asesinato
de más de 40 activistas que protestaban
contra la brutalidad policial
multitudinarias marchas se vivieron en
todo el país durante dos semanas en
contra de la violencia sistemática del
escuadrón especial anti robo que el
pasado 12 de octubre fue disuelto por la
presión de las protestas
los ojos de bryant se llenan de lágrimas
cuando recuerda como las manifestaciones
pacíficas que llevaron a miles de
jóvenes nigerianos a salir a las calles
para protestar contra la brutalidad
policial se tornaron extremadamente
violentas con al menos 56 muertos
este lugar era una zona de guerra pero
era más el ejército luchando contra
civiles civiles desarmados civiles
pacíficos civiles que ejercían su
derecho constitucional
el 8 de octubre comenzó la ola de
manifestaciones en todo el país
lideradas por jóvenes impulsadas a
través de las redes sociales el motivo
de su rabia la violencia sistemática de
la unidad de la policía a sharp por sus
siglas en inglés escuadrón especial
antirrobo ahora disuelto pero también
para exigir el cese de la brutalidad
policial contra la población el martes
un panel judicial independiente comenzó
con las audiencias en lagos para
investigar los reclamos contra el sal
una de las demandas de los manifestantes
en el caso de que no consigamos justicia
entraremos a ver al mundo que este panel
está siendo parcializado
pero por ahora estamos estudiando el
progreso de los procedimientos del panel
y creemos que vamos a conseguir justicia
para ellos
a partir del 20 de octubre las protestas
fueron reprimidas por las fuerzas de
seguridad con disparos y agresiones
contra los congregados la conmoción de
los asesinatos en las marchas ha dejado
el movimiento de protesta tambaleándose
con los activistas teniendo
persecuciones pero la ira de una
generación frustrada por la mala
gobernanza está hirviendo en el país más
poblado de áfrica y vislumbra nuevas
manifestaciones las autoridades
electorales de tanzania oficializaron la
victoria del presidente john mcfall y
quien fue reelegido para un segundo
período el pasado 28 de octubre el
mandatario se hizo con cerca del 84 por
ciento de los votos pero los resultados
son cuestionados por la oposición que
alega fraude y pide la repetición de los
comicios
tindall y su el principal rival del
presidente fue brevemente detenido luego
de que la policía frustrar a las
protestas convocadas por los contrarios
al gobierno le hizo quien obtuvo cerca
del 13 por ciento de la votación también
denunció el fuerte despliegue de la
policía en las calles y arresto de
funcionarios del partido así como de sus
simpatizantes
el presidente de guinea alpha condé ganó
un tercer mandato con el 59.49 de los
votos así lo declaró la comisión
electoral nacional independiente el
candidato de la oposición cellou dalein
diallo recibió el 30 y 3.50 por ciento
de los votos en la participación de
votantes fue casi del 80% las tensiones
políticas en torno a las elecciones en
la nación se volvieron violentas después
de que el opositor se proclamará ganador
antes de los resultados oficiales
escenas de alegría en las calles de
conakry los partidarios de alpha condé
celebran su victoria en las elecciones
presidenciales del país la comisión
electoral de guinea publicó los
resultados que sitúan al candidato de 82
años como ganador
los cándidos profesión alfa con llega al
cáncer el candidato alpha condé de la
agrupación del pueblo guineano es
declarado electo en la primera vuelta de
las elecciones presidenciales con el 59
49 por ciento de los votos
el rival de conde en los comicios se
lucha en la india lo ha conseguido el
33.5 por ciento de los votos pero el
candidato que había reclamado la
victoria antes de los resultados
oficiales declaró que presentará una
denuncia no vamos a protestar contra
este robo electoral ya estamos en el
proceso de recopilación de datos lo cual
es muy difícil dado que nuestras
oficinas están ocupadas no tenemos
acceso a nuestros documentos pero aún
así vamos a llevar esto al tribunal
constitucional sin hacernos demasiadas
ilusiones según la oposición que hunde
está violando la ley al aferrarse al
poder en efecto en marzo forzó una
enmienda constitucional alegando que
contribuiría a modernizar el país pero
que sobre todo le permitió evitar el
límite de dos mandatos como presidente
mientras tanto la policía fue desplegada
cuando se anunciaban los resultados ya
que las
y tenían una reacción violenta el
viernes las fuerzas de seguridad
dispersaron a manifestantes después de
que se contarán los primeros votos que
prometían al facundo un tercer mandato
israel y sudán anunciaron la
normalización de sus relaciones la
decisión provocó una serie de reacciones
del pueblo sudanés que pasan de la
indignación a una aceptación pragmática
décadas de hostilidad de repente a punto
de terminar en las calles de jartúm los
ciudadanos sudaneses expresaron
sentimientos mixtos sobre la
normalización de las relaciones con
israel algunos ven la decisión como una
necesidad práctica después de
movimientos similares de vecinos árabes
como baréin y emiratos árabes unidos- la
normalización se ha convertido en una
realidad inevitable es el interés de
nuestro país porque muchos países árabes
han normalizado sus relaciones e israel
se ha hecho presente en nuestra vida
pública y en la vida de todos los países
árabes
otros son aún más optimistas sobre el
regreso de sudán a la escena mundial
después de años de conflicto y
aislamiento bajo el mandato de omar
al-bashir apoyó la normalización de los
lazos con israel porque allana el camino
para las relaciones internacionales
especialmente con eeuu se espera que el
acuerdo negociado por eeuu para abrir la
cooperación económica y comercial con
israel se centre primero en la
agricultura
sudán busca que el acuerdo ayude a
aliviar una crisis económica cada vez
más profunda
tanto si normalizamos las relaciones con
israel como
israel debe beneficiar a sudán de alguna
manera en la agricultura por ejemplo
porque sé que israel es uno de los más
fuertes del mundo en el ámbito
tecnológico pero muchos en jartún siguen
oponiéndose a la idea y continúan
considerando a israel como un enemigo
del mundo árabe cualquier país que
normalice las relaciones con israel no
encontrará más comunicación y deshonra
es probable que una completa
implementación de las relaciones lleve
algún tiempo ya que sudán todavía está
en proceso de formar un gobierno civil
después de la caída de omar al-bashir el
año pasado
y la justicia internacional anunció el
traslado a la sede de la corte penal
internacional en la haya de felicia
kabuga acusado de ser uno de los
principales promotores del genocidio de
ruanda en 1994 inicialmente el juicio de
cauca se iba a realizar en tanzania
donde por costumbre se adelantan las
audiencias en contra de los acusados del
genocidio de ruanda pero un juez ordenó
su traslado a la haya cauda fue
capturado en parís el pasado 22 de mayo
después de 25 años prófugo se le acusa
de proporcionar recursos a las milicias
hutus que mataron a más de 800.000
tutsis
y finalizamos con música del cantante
tan sano diamond platinum también
conocido como simbad estas son las
imágenes de su más reciente videoclip
titulado cachirí en colaboración con el
reconocido rapero quin 98
[Música]
bueno
infante muchachos y muchachas muchachos
[Música]
y más
y hasta aquí esta emisión de áfrica
siete días recuerde que si quiere
repetir esta u otra emisión de nuestro
programa puede ir a través de nuestra
página web www punto francisco
cuatro.com kachin y shan kachin y shan
y cachetadas
[Música]